there's a spot now I couldn't fit in
there as we too tight that one no you
can make it you're a great parallel
Parker oh and what can I get for you - I
have the Brussels sprout and Friday
Excel excellent and for you sir I'll
have the swordfish we actually just ran
out of a swordfish is there something
else I can get for you okay find
something find something steak red meat
candy red meat too much cholesterol
watching that any fish fish fish fish
fish fish fish fish fish fish you're
gonna have to find something help me
help me help me Hey oh my god they're
laughing at me trying I can't the
machines broke it's not taking it it's
not taking it's not my fault it's not
taking it oh you know what this is not
what I ordered
do you mind getting the waiters
attention Andy um boss said she's
looking for you how much you even leave
for tips
as reading this weekend out of
California keeps up in this drought two
years we'll be out of water price we pay
for living in a desert Oh your father